hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 2 now
we're in the basement of some sewer
somewhere in a place so labyrinthian
that I don't fully understand exactly
where I am or where I'm going but I have
been making progress because I do have a
rook now I don't know what the rook is -
or if I can solve the puzzle with the
rook because I think there's still some
Queen here that I need to get before I
can actually finish this so or maybe
there's even - because I know there's
definitely one but I don't know if
there's not - once they just grab that
one did I just grab the one I think I
just grabbed the one but unless that
wasn't the one and there was something
else then I got to go back up anyway
because I got the key with a label on it
anyway so I'm gonna go do that and
that's all I know for now okay makes
sense all right we're gonna I just just
gonna forget about it just forget about
it I need to get out of here because I
need to go this way to be able to get
unless there was a lift no I dropped
down on that that's not a lift unless
there's a call that I can do that what's
the sign for it's nothing okay there's
nothing here there's nothing there okay
that doesn't make any sense at all so
now that I know that for certain I'm
gonna go back up this way and I'm gonna
go back up the I'm gonna go down the
stairs what are you doing where am i god
I don't even remember where I'm supposed
to go I think yeah yeah if I go down
this way and then I go down that way and
then I go around maybe there's another
one of the pipe pump things now when I
open that up to drop down here and where
did this go I killed that thing with a
bunch of kaboom errs where am I where
the hell am i okay we're fine
we're okay because I now know exactly
where I'm gonna go
this pops yes exactly this is where I
got that thing oh hey how you don't know
oh yeah oh hey all right anyway buddy
hey stupid idiot I'm just gonna go in
here don't mind me I gotta get in the
treatment facility oh you foolish fool
Oh what is that
Oh gun powder okay good whoa
lots of lockers any good stuff hell yeah
lockers no this weird oh okay so that'll
be true that's probably fine I'm not too
terribly worried about that so I don't
know where this goes but no time like
the present to find out so let's get it
on
okay how much I got eight bullets of
this one get to this canidates uh all
right good okay so long as I am
conservative about my ammo I should be
okay I don't know where the hell I am
but I almost just passed by bullets mag
bullets yes I like this all right so I
got big bullets I don't know if there's
a reason they gave me big bullets but I
got big bullets nonetheless all right
here perfect love it oh [ __ ] okay what
do we have in here anything of value huh
grenade oh yes please no come on okay
yes please
ooh whoa what is that oh oh this is
these stars oh I can do this i dub
where's I know where I have there's
gotta be
wait there's gotta be like um operators
room how do I get to the operators room
I'd have to go back okay I need to go
get the stars thing because that's
important because that seems like
important so I'll be right back this is
important everybody back off this is
important I bet this is important
probably important and there's probably
no other way to get it
besides right here and I gotta go
the way back there's worth it this will
be worth it and we're back and this is
totally gonna be worth it because this
is the only thing that I need the USB
dongle key that's probably exactly what
I need and I can put this away and we're
good to go
yeah II wasted a lot of time doing a
whole lot of nothing but this is gonna
be I'll be back I'll be back trust me
this is gonna be totally worth it
you son of a dick no stop just no big
not good no get big knife aah missed me
missed me
now you gotta kiss me don't kiss me
actually that's a bad idea and I'll be
the stair sees and three two one baby
and shubbu ski okay
boom boom boom I would have been very
mad if that was not the right place for
that
what
oh I know what it need me I need to put
the dango back I need to put the dum
good I need to put the dongle away
perfect now the dongle is way perfect
easy peasy lemon squeezy I don't know
what that is but it looks awesome
I love it already I love it so much
already I love so much of it I love
every part of it I love everything about
it
what does it do examine reduces recoil
and imparts extra speed to bullet
somehow okay it's so long
it's too long god damn it it's too long
why it's okay it's fine
cuz I've got so much space that it's
barely any problem at all so that is an
even more powerful tyrant stopper that's
basically it's only job so long as I got
that we're good to go okay moving on
finally just only a little bit into this
game and I'm finally moving on here we
are it's all good in this neighborhood
okay wow this is a long ominous hallway
why is this here there's some reason for
this should I be worried about this my
little worried about this okay this
looks a lot wait no wait a minute wait
in the hacking what what how did I get
back here no way won't even let me jump
down how did I get back here why am i
back here what the hell
all right well that's bizarre how in the
hell did that that doesn't make any
sense but I came this way when I first
came down here so where the hell that
means
oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh but
that means that I could have God that
means I could have just done the thing
oh I could have just gone up here for
the case cuz I know that there's a case
there's a case right god damn it I ran
all the way it's fine it's fine I can do
this here and then lotta bing bada boom
I'm back in Marvin I'm back baby
you know me I'm back it's me it's your
boy it's your boy Leon that's my name
Leon it's Leon Leon's back Marvin Marvin
alright this is done apparently this is
done apparently alright Marvin Marvin
Marvin Oh Marvin Marvin there you are
why am i back here why am i back here
how does it all connect to here okay
so there must be a reason that it
connects to the police room right right
right I've got uh I've got out I've got
a roll of film I've got a roll of film
okay so I just need to get around Marvin
but I've got a roll of film
okay that's gotta be good I know there's
lictors all over the place but that's
okay
they can lick whatever they want to lick
that doesn't mean that they have to lick
me okay so lick sirs be licking but that
doesn't mean that I need to bother with
them so I need to go directly to the
right here oh no that's not good
none of that okay I need to go get it
from here
perfect roll the film that's right
something about a hiding place now I
don't know what that's all about but
okay what what okay this looks like it's
in that that kind of like press
conference room maybe this one I don't
know where this is this is some desk Wow
okay I don't know what that means but
I'm gonna try to take it as some kind of
evidence I may have to kill this lichter
which I wouldn't want to do but beggars
can't be choosers at this point plus I
can skate right by it
which I totally can't i totes get god
dammit damn you
okay whatever I've got plenty of health
there you go just fall over and die
Jesus I'm sure that killed it for dead
for good yeah I'm sure that did that ha
Boesky okay so I can use one of my many
medicinal herbs I've got one on me right
now
I can take another hit it's fine okay so
what I got to do is I gotta get over
down
Marvin not now your attitude can rest
for just another second I think one of
the things that he was talking about was
in here in this thing that the tyrant
will broke down I think yeah right here
yeah this oh all right
that's oh hi buddy how are you are you
okay
okay so it definitely wasn't ah I have
no idea where that other one would be
cuz this is very obscure but is some
desk it might be in the Stars office
that might be it
hang on it might be the Stars office I'm
not 100% sure but it might be Marvin
Marvin Marvin nope Marvin that's a big
note maybe it was in here is this it
it is Oh wooden box that seems real cool
alright
wooden box what does that mean some good
some good baby what do you got alright
okay that's pretty good
alright that's that's that's pretty good
I was right number one I was right which
I'm very proud of but number two I got
that and that's real cool I still don't
know why since the library is not fully
explored because I think it is unless
there's like some book here in the Shelf
maybe I haven't seen oh what's the oh
there's some bullets and are we done now
okay yeah we're done okay
cool that's good I mean that's not not
bad not the best thing in the world but
I'll take bullets nonetheless I am very
very not heavy on bullets okay so what I
don't think is I don't think that
there's any reason I need to go back
right now I got some upgrades for my gun
which is really cool but I don't think
that's the exact reason that I need to
be here so Marvin I will see you when I
get back don't worry about me cuz I am
NOT
important just pretend like I wasn't
here and just keep slipping into the
cold embrace of death eternal so I'll
see you around the bend
um yeah okay so it's good to know that
there's a way back up from there but
what I need to do is I need to find one
more piece of the puzzle
I think the Queen piece whoa Jazz
Festival Oh s Z F ah s ZF is there there
was one where was that
SEF there was a locker that had
something but SEF okay so whenever I
find that again let's go please that's
what I'll do
SEF got it okay good to know um what is
over this way more sewer god damn it is
there any way to get back to where I was
before I don't think so oh I'd have to
go get the piece you don't do that okay
the only other place that I haven't seen
or explored or done anything about is
this oh my god oh yeah no joke it's
getting worse this was the place God
died wha all right after so much time of
not making oh my god that's up that's I
know what that is I'm gonna just equip
this bad boy Hey wakey-wakey eggs in
there oh [ __ ]
Hey Oh take one of those
and I can't please can I please I should
have used a grenade
I should he's not a grenade should you
not actually just screw you and should
you stun a grenade from the get-go
should've just done two grenades didn't
just taking my lumps cuz that's what it
was gonna cost anyway so why didn't I
just do it oh oh boy okay you know what
I'll it's not no no no no okay all right
try this
good god you suck you suck really hard
uh yeah big crybaby I probably didn't
even need to shoot you all that much I
could have just gone away with anything
else oh good okay this is the way out
definitely well that's good I'm glad for
that thank you for that that's very
helpful
except it's not and I wish that I were
dead that would be a preferable
experience to what I'm experiencing than
this because that looks like hell I
thought I was done with you you know
what yeah I'm actually I'm gonna test
out the theory that I don't even know
okay I need to fight you you're quickly
in the way of where I'm going well I
don't know if to shoot your eye or your
big four shots really four four shots
from the big boomer is all it took to
get you done all right
sure some evil within [ __ ] going on
here okay oh good great great this door
alright who's there hello it's me mark
flyer back at it again with another game
the video I hear you
can I just please he-hey yeah gotcha
okay good to know what is this oh boy
there's a dead body
it's always good there's an herb always
good okay sure
supplies storage room this is probably
where the keys gonna be I can't believe
I beat around the bush for this for so
long without knowing that this is the
way that I needed to go I thought oh
there's a flame to her all right
all is forgiven all's good oh yeah oh no
but but to flame flower but to
flamethrower what about the flame flower
what about the flamethrower can I do
anything about this or is this just
locked from the other side I imagine
it's locked from the other side and I'll
get back to this eventually oh how am I
gonna do that
that's confusing okay very confusing I
wish I had brought another plug maybe oh
no it's the same thing either way okay
is there something in this that I need
to worry about probably okay that all
right that's you here I guess okay I
don't know what good that did
oh I know a good that did okay I need
that somehow to get over here but what's
going on up here first
ah you alive okay buddy
oh no he's alive oh good whatever who
cares just a normal zombie what could a
normal zombie do to me
oh hey set another queen errs it's the
king the King part Oh fun okay good to
know
scary bastard
you son-of-a-bitch Oh screw you so hard
yeah yeah fall over come on fall over
Jesus how are you yeah yeah I got to
stop shooting you in the head apparently
because if it doesn't work how are you
still alive don't present vine ass to me
I will destroy you
oh my god okay all right let me see if I
can get into this flamethrower a room
first
all right King plug easy put the plug in
get the king there we go in the kingly
weapon now this is what I'm talking
about now that is what I am talking
about that right there that is the thing
of which I am referring to that is real
nice all right so get that there oh wait
let me I think I know it's anyway I need
to go so I need to unlock this just like
that I need to take this and I need to
oh [ __ ] okay and easy peasy okay got him
so long as I yeah this is all good no
get to forget the thing we gotta get out
of here okay we've got everything I
think I don't know why I opened that
because I didn't need to do that at all
did whatever sure I don't know why that
was needed to be unlocked but I've got
this now the flamethrower and I've got
some extra flamethrower
ammo I don't know what the benefit of
this is gonna be in the long run oh [ __ ]
okay but I got all the pieces which
means that I can finally unlock the
stupid chess puzzle [ __ ] that it's
been holding out on me for forever
all right am I gonna need this big
flamethrower the answer is a big maybe I
like maybes I like a lot of uncertainty
in my horror games this is the best part
of it that's my favorite part all right
beautiful pretty all right so this is a
quick hop and a jump that's a quick hop
and a jump not up here not hoppy jumpy
up here it's a quick hop and a jump hop
skip and a jump to the place I need to
go I ain't gonna worry about those big
guys no mo that's how this is gonna go
ok so I got all the plugs so I think if
I go up this way it should get me
relatively close to where I need to go
so I don't need to worry about nothing I
should have known
I've been wandering around so far and
wide you son of a [ __ ] I'm not even
gonna bother with you you know I'm now I
mean I'm not even gonna bother with you
I'm not even gonna bother with you not
even gonna bother with you not even
gonna bother with you you know what
somehow I got away from you I don't know
how what I did
so you suck I awesome and that's the
long and short of it oh I've got one
pull regular pull it left I got a bunch
of BIGBANG ease but I want to save the
BIGBANG ease in case I need a Big Bang
II I am good yeah I have got what I need
and let me just save so I can get son of
a [ __ ]
and I've made whoopty-doo 20 minutes of
progress all it took me an hour yeah all
right so I don't know where this goes I
think this is the Queen one sure maybe
I've got this all set up and ready to go
there's the king one that it nope okay
come on all right
Reed okay rook and Knight are on the
same wall the bishop and queen are next
to each other Queen and the rook we're
opposite each other too okay so is that
the rook that's the rook
that's the bishop
Vishnu Budhan queen aren't next to each
other I mean this makes sense the
Knights they're the pawn has to be there
the Queen and the the rook or opposite
each other the bishop and Queen aren't
next to each other the rook and Knight
are on the same wall so they have to be
here oh I had I had the Queen and the
king mixed up whoops that was my bad I
thought the Queen was the king all right
hey you all right you festered a few
wounds there your garbage got in your
wood if you lick it with garbage and you
just smear some poop on it should get
feeling better right away you're gonna
feel so good you gonna feel so good
you're gonna feel so so unbelievably
good let me actually I'll be right back
ada
you can rest a little bit longer but I
need to take care of this because my
inventory is a little full I got a
little herb management to do this you
know I am about herblore love me some
herblore can you please just combine
here put this away I don't needed that
in there all good I've got so much herb
I have never had more herb in my life so
great oh let me get out my flamethrower
am I probably don't need it I probably
don't need it that badly I don't need it
it's all good huh
how are you eight are you good are you
good at are you good yeah you're good
heydo you're good what's going on here
what is all this main power room that
seems important main power song hey how
you doing
damnable interesting red herb perfect
put that right there I'll mix that in
later all right
nailed it who needs a hacking device huh
not me I know exactly what I got going
on all the time it's pretty good like
that oh my god oh my god oh oh my god oh
my god
oh holy [ __ ]
umm oh jeez I'm so Kay uh Wow this
problem for corner strat Oh Joey
um well if only I could suck how am i
fire oh [ __ ]
I'm on fire I'm on fire I'm gonna choke
down some herbs I don't know what's
going on here and I don't know why
can you poke a hole in this maybe
oh geez that guy said howdy
okay I'm gonna go now I guess I guess
it's what I have to do all right yeah I
don't know either I don't get it either
I don't get it it's a little weird to me
too
oh I'm just gonna be and a real nice and
gentle like I'm in no hurry I've never
been in a hurry I don't even know what a
hurry means okay here we go everybody
hop down to the candy shop okay oh boy
what's this I push this button oh you're
here come here I'm guessing this is
gonna swing around Oh perfect no please
I don't want it okay here we go I'm up
bring it back around that's right I
gotta swing it back around come here you
come ere are you
yeah that's right and in three two
that was supposed to miss me and hit him
it's supposed to miss me miss me with
that [ __ ] um okay okay all right buddy
okay listen listen listen ah desert
wow I need to hit this button please
thank you gonna hit that okay scuse me
flashbang flashbang flashbang - [ __ ]
okay Wow
yeah it didn't work out so good okay so
I know what I need to do I need to hit
this I need to grab this flashbang II I
need to grab whatever this is Oh another
knife perfect exactly what I was hoping
for
let me grab these bullets here grab
these okay hey oh hey listen you the
friend I I don't like you you don't like
me bye
okay that's good listen listen buddy can
you agree to disagree and take one of
those and stay there for a long time
stay stay stay stay stay stay I used
both of my flash booms so you can maybe
you could oh [ __ ] Howie okay lesson
lesson lesson buddy listen all right how
about charging bull tactics Oh
charging bull tactic not working he's
not charging little bit oh yeah yeah
yeah
all right here we go we're gonna do this
the old-fashioned way
my old-fashioned way I mean I this is
not gonna work in no way no how
all right stay there stay there stay
there
you are really ugly all right that's the
second time you've fallen into the abyss
can you stay down if you could just stay
down let's hope let's hope and let's
hope it's not the last to me all right
whatever we have fun here okay anything
else that I missed up here oh wait this
is there's more bullets somewhere Oh
perfect
oh I forgot about these okay big boy
bullets okay that's good so everything's
great
good great I'm so happy about that hey
listen small detour small little side
thing I don't know what happens is
really weird you don't mind it is it's
not a big deal anyway whatever is this
not a big deal so anyway wasn't there
like um wasn't there like uh let me go
happy to go up it's safe I would go up I
just feel real I need to write my memoir
I just a few more pages I feel like I
need that to sell my life story just
keeps getting more interesting by the
second just feel like it's necessary to
really capitulate as much as I can about
everything anyway stay there stay put
okay in store and I don't need any
health do I do you think I do I don't
think I do
I'm probably fine I got a green herb and
Bloor I'm probably fine I'm probably fun
I could probably take I I'm only caution
I'm only caution I could probably take a
few more hits I'm probably fine I'm
probably fine ADA hey how you doing uh
just gonna go there's you dead hater
oh [ __ ] maybe I shouldn't uh there
shouldn't a wandered around so much
heydo it or are you you yoo-hoo hey you
I can't get out I don't know just do it
I can't walk like this okay maybe it
won't you don't know that I don't know
where I got that I don't have any more
spray I don't have any more herbs I got
a whole lot of nothing so what do we do
now get yourself out of here while you
still can
I'm not just gonna leave you like this
you don't understand
situations worse than I thought you're
not getting rid of me that easy
that's my so cute
so cute that's so cute
grab my broad shoulder maybe you should
take off your high heels right the nest
okay that's where the virus tablets are
you up for this
I think I could fit in my schedule yeah
so smooth finger guns on the way out oh
hell yeah also isn't it a little obvious
that those samples would be in the lab
okay whatever you say okay where'd you
get that excuse me sorry could you hurry
up a little bit sorry pip pardon me
excuse me excuse me could you please
just get Adil a little bit more could
you please just skedaddle a little bit
faster all right excuse me pardon me all
right what have we got my memoir by the
way Leon's diary day one hour three I am
in a tizzy this lady won't stop wearing
heels when she obviously needs to hurry
probably not good on her leg cut it off
[Laughter]
okay yeah the emotional turmoil of that
would be just far beyond reproach
you couldn't even fathom the emotional
damage that would do yeah well whatever
it's a-you know it's whatever is a
little morbid you've tried to cheer up a
little bit maybe be a little bit happier
or something
access denied oh there we go
easy peasy all right what a nice cable
car that's lovely nice that's nice he's
just taking a snooze there well I gotta
work oh yeah I'm ready okay let's do
this
what happened to Claire who's Claire I
don't even remember a Claire whatever
Claire yeah Yeah right
okay that's convenient wasn't planning
on it
Oh spooky
you know what I was thinking I can't
wait for the FBI to raid umbrella
headquarters and take those bastards to
justice
I agree but to be clear you're not
working in official capacity this is a
federal case once we get the g-virus I'm
back on my own hey Leon trust me
trust me honestly if I didn't you
probably be dead
I thought I might need your help and I
was right if you can secure the g-virus
I can make sure what happened in Raccoon
City never happens again
yeah you say it yourself it's a federal
case I don't have the authority look at
me a liability now I'm gonna finish this
case you're the last hope my god
I'm not gonna leave you here what if
your attack with you need help
oh hell yeah that seems oddly
inappropriate but the ride
hell yeah I gotta see this through and I
want to see you again
nice this makes total sense
we've known each other for nigh on an
hour
please much time no we don't you're
right I will okay all right yeah babe
don't worry sugar lips
I got this under control if thing good
yeah okay we're going for it let's do
this for love I'm in love I hope
everybody heard me I'm in love I've got
a lot of love in my life now didn't
before and then I have loved to fight
for I would have fought anyway but now I
have love in my heart totally logical
it's true love it's my soul mate is in
this bunker hope that doesn't come back
too emotionally hard me love okay anyway
I'm in love this can't stop saying that
over and over again I Leon I am in love
Leon s Kennedy is in love hello may I
enter your lab please I would love thank
you
what huh I don't know what are you
talking about what are you saying what
are you talking about I have no idea a
man in love does not concern himself
with safety okay cool thanks you know
I'm in love love police anybody in here
need some education on how to love oh
that is that's a good there's a good
sign okay alright hey how you doing hey
hey Wow oh oh how many of you were in
here miss okay oh oh geez okay oh boy
all right I'll take the poof the
flammable flammables
okay I'll take that thank you for giving
me the thing I need to kill you oh come
on
there we go
and what what what okay you're dead okay
no you're not dead you're not yeah hey I
said stop I said stop and you're done
okay can I have that knife back second
knife nobody expects a second knife are
you kidding me just go to sleep
sweet baby please go to sleep
oh you silly [ __ ] what was the point of
all that did I even need to come in here
did is there any reason oh hello okay I
don't know where this goes but I'm going
just like in the sewers I'm just kind of
running forward as fast as I can hoping
for the best but never gonna get it so
you know how it is you know I would do
you know how I is and how it'd be all
right gunpowder in the kitchen I see
nothing wrong with that that makes
perfect sense
knife actually that okay that doesn't
make sense to have in the kitchen that
that makes plenty of sense pancakes
Oh way I don't even believe it all right
hello no no no no no no what are you
doing what are you doing what do you
know what do you think you're doing no
this
maybe I should just finish you off with
yeah that's what I thought
you are annoying you're very annoying
very extremely exceptionally annoying
oh hey shake my hand why don't you look
at that maybe I can combine this oh yeah
it's already coming in handy are do you
know what it's all about and there's
some shotgun shells which I desperately
need having that shotgun in a long time
lockers any surprise whoa I don't know
what that does
Oh regulator okay make it more efficient
all right easy enough instant upgrade
for that I don't even have to wait there
was this muff muff muff knife muff smoth
slump lord I don't know what you want
from me
okay so I got that I'm assuming that was
important for my forward progress in
this game there was a grenade in the
cafeteria oh that's all right sure
whatever all right natural natural
that's the NAP room there we go the NAP
room and take a nap
yeah okay take a forever nap shooting
these are dead all right what's going on
here this looks awfully nice yeah yeah
yeah yeah I have no idea where the
g-virus would be here either
probably not out in the open though if I
just had to guess do I have I wish I had
a big gunpowder I'm gonna save until I'm
gonna save the big gunpowder because I
feel like that's important but as far as
the fuel goes let me take out some of
that put this back in let me reload
this okay and then I'm gonna put in
store cool
move this here put this way I probably
don't need
I probably maybe if I maybe if I put
this shotgun away I won't be tempted to
use it and that way I can stock up on
some ammo for it instead of constantly
using it all the time and I can rely on
more on the flamethrower which seems
like a good move
okay I'm gonna do that let me see how
that do for me cuz if that do for me
good then it might help me save security
room that sounds like shotgun shells yes
please okay well okay Oh map oh good
great good good for me Pizza probably
still fresh laptop probably important
bad weird blood on the bed I don't know
why that's there that's that's weird
okay whatever you somebody shouldn't
have been napping I suppose main shaft
they know my nickname whoa holy [ __ ]
what is this it's like the lab from Day
of the Dead oh okay
alpha 2 ghost target moving to the west
area must be going to retrieve the
g-virus an antiviral agent this ghost
understood rendezvous to point there'll
be three Roger this is alpha arrived at
destination understood stand by for
target this is alpha I've got eyes on
target he's going to open the safe
Roger awaiting signal got eyes on the
g-virus we're going in dr. Burke and
you'll come along with us quietly yeah I
don't know how to tell you this but that
that data might be old that information
might be really old you might not have
up-to-date information on what you're
doing here
good level four how am I gonna get level
four I don't even level three
- garbage where's this go link okay so
that's the level three area so I gotta
go to level two first okay all right
this makes logical sense also how the
hell did they dig this under Raccoon
City and what is that yeah some kind of
like arc reactor Tony Stark [ __ ]
going on here alright whatever east area
here we go ah
oh that's contaminated all right cool
good hello hi how you doing
anybody seen some kind of a virus going
on here
maybe maybe starts with the letter G
anybody know what's in here oh my god oh
my god holy [ __ ] Jesus oh oh oh
plant monsters I love it and I hate it
but I love it
okay Oh oh hey hi dude you are gonna be
an enemy you I can tell I can already
tell you're gonna be an enemy you're
gonna drop down you're gonna actually
kill me and I don't like it
oh I don't like it those sounds are not
necessary all right oh no no no no no no
no nothing why do you go faster when I
shoot you can you please die thank you
and I'm gonna slice you up this really
does a lot of damage to plant based
enemies give you a trim huh your your
head just look a little pushy I don't
like the music well I like the music
okay now I'll never have to see them
ever again so that's good I'm glad that
I endured that and it'll never have to
come across their pass ever again hey
how you doing here hey what's going on
input code okay I don't know the code
don't know the code
oh alright so I'm guessing I need to get
some kind of solution that's gonna
dissolve this oh my goodness gracious oh
my Oh something tells me it might be a
bad idea to be in this place something
tells me ah
something tells me not the best place to
be fired is pretty good I guess
yeah there we go it's okay there you go
yes a good that's good that's a good
pass good boy good boy
okay well fired us real good that's good
to know good to know good to know
very good to know I can't get up there
yet until I need to it is just one more
for good measure
yeah there we go yeah well more for good
measure
you asked it that's good
I'll see you around the bend okay
goodbye
okay oh that's a code okay am I supposed
to remember this okay these are it's
kind of Korean symbols so yeah EEE
neat get yah yah e mute get aa kind of
yeah yeah okay
yeah in it get ah yeah time - yeah I
mean that's kind of what it is okay okay
yeah yeah it's good yeah okay
easy peasy lemon squeeze me uh you still
causing problems over there are you
still being a still being us silly Billy
okay you
have fun okay you burn yeah okay you
burn out okay all right so well it's
over here drug testing lab that seems
important oh this seems important what
is this oh hello herbicide synthesis
okay 43 herbicide synthesis place empty
cartridge and solution add required
amount of um B number 21 P dash epsilon
cool immediately plant the 43 exhibits
astounding growth of something
unfortunate of where the core it may be
hard to control in the event of an
unforeseen accident manufacture the
herbicide using the instructions above
in order to minimize damage Lukey yeah
right
oh no I can't do that I don't know what
that says okay great what is wrong with
you okay I don't know what's wrong with
that guy but it has nothing to do with
me
alright what about this what about that
okay I can't get into there and still
like hmm okay yeah big gunpowder okay
good use that to make more shotgun
shells okay good all right so let's see
where this trap door goes and let's burn
you yeah
that's gonna get right by don't mind me
don't mind me don't mind me don't mind
me hello hi Howdy Doody this flame
through her
it is pretty baller oh I hate this place
whatever this is I hate it oh I hate it
so much I hate it oh I hate a big gun
powder good great map great okay great
great
all right okay bloody plant don't know
why janitorial supply some kind of
bathroom but as no surfer room hey
that's a bathroom yeah Oh which one of
y'all want to get up that's what I want
to know who's the ward huh
word for biggest dick okay I don't know
which one of y'all want to get up then I
ain't worried I don't know what I need
probably a battery or some judging by
that I don't have a battery so Murph
ain't gonna get power Oh trophy I didn't
know that was actually a thing that I
needed to use okay well no one is
getting up so I'm guessing the nobody
needs to worry about me
okay I can make a whole bunch of this
again I've got so many of these so many
with so many of these I've never used oh
wow dad now you get up all your big
babies you done with your nap all shake
[ __ ] shame shame why why okay I need to
use my fricking time to use it
okay the defense
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah okay yeah okay
all right you burned you burned you're
done you're done okay you're done you're
done you're burned
okay how about dad just keep burning it
there you go come on there you go your
crispy best be all right you're done are
you all done are we done
we done good great great good done okay
I've still got my defense up from that
thing which is really handy why I even
bothered there's something over there
than I need probably not no there's
nothing over there that I need why would
there be I don't even need to bother
with you
you're like Marvin you're like my friend
bye you sack of [ __ ] stop doing that
pieces of garbage all right what have we
got in here
okay that's unnecessary can I make more
shotgun shells they're in there and
combine okay okay what's in the locker
great all right let's just burn
[Applause]
can you just burn down already
no my god really okay there you yes fall
over stupid idiot can I have my knife
back did you did you eat up all my knife
did I burn my knife down
Oh signal modulator if that's all right
cool I got a signal modulator somebody's
note everybody's turned if edge of fied
they keep coming back again and again
burn them all burn them until their
whole body is black with ash there's no
other way okay well I've been doing that
I've kind of also been using up all my
burn oh hey what up let's go the big old
no what the I can't believe you're still
surprised by this Leon it's pretty much
the same as it's always been for this
entire duration of this adventure which
is exactly where I want to be because
there is a chest here alright um I need
to put not a hold on to that I need to
put this away
I need to put this here and I need the
fuel here and then I need to reload this
reload and then I'm gonna save this for
the eventual plant-based boss that I'm
gonna get because I know there's gonna
be a plant-based boss if that's like a
guaranteed there's gonna be some kind of
plant boss I'm gonna be in a plant area
is gonna be plants it's just gonna I
just funny feeling that that's exactly
how this is gonna go down
and if that is how this is gonna go down
then I need you people paired for it
what's in the presentation roof senior
staff BC facility control solution
sprinkle system okay okay I need the
signal modulator which I have so I need
to go back first because the first
signal modulation area was way way way
in the back it was all the way in the
restroom of the first area so I need to
go there and I need to see what signal
modulation that's gonna do
and then come back okay make sense cool
great why is it why don't they have an
elevator reserved for just like their
senior staff that seems like that seems
[ __ ] all right nap room let's see
what we got here muff
I like muff so oh I uh I know what I
know what it means I need to examine it
to knit - muff yeah oh yeah yeah
oh there we go we're tuned in the muff
baby I think let's clap muff back in
there pop it in alright hey what did
that Joe [ __ ] very posh [ __ ] there are
you know what I'm just gonna alright
anyway
new fanny pack I love it I love it I
love it I love it I love it I've got so
many Fanny's alright so I did that and
now I know what that is there's
something in here Wayne Lee's note what
the hell is happening they're dead all
dead it was those men in black USS
headquarters but why is in their job to
protect us white brains in a sea of red
this can't be happening dear God why
didn't everybody say I was a genius a
genius like me can't die in a place like
this I always got results they're
screwing me maybe I'll screw them I'll
win the Nobel I'm a hero genius a god I
will not die I will and then this seems
like you're dead ahh seems like I blew
up your genius brain all over the floor
I'm very sorry about that that is my bad
and I apologize for everything is
anything else unlocked here when the
power went on it's probably nothing else
I would imagine that anything else would
be unlocked would it snow didn't seem
like that seize the case maybe I could
get some food yes I look around here I
sure AM hungry that's the first thing I
think about anyway goodbye see ya see
you goodbye farewell see you goodbye
alright so now I gotta go find Murph cuz
if I can find Murph then I might be able
to get some more bonus stuff or maybe
there's gonna be something that I need
that is gonna be advancing the storyline
which is also just good but also I could
use another fanny pack which I really
like having fanny packs
is this all I got to say about that I
really like fanny packs and I like
fiddling with Murph Murph is cool Murph
is fun
I like Murph alright let's go this way
and move
baby this way oh [ __ ] burning there you
go yeah yeah burn em burn em burn em
burn em burn em all the way down nope
burn keep burning and three two one
nope till your burn black got to be
completely black
there you go that's more like it there
we go
perfect great I don't know if I burned
them all to that level of burnt but I'm
gonna make sure that they're all burnt
to that level of bird the next time that
I see them okay make sense also what was
the code for this thing because they
don't remember it was I this nope okay I
don't remember what it was and I'm not
gonna be able to guess it so I'm not
gonna bother alright hello anybody still
alive here oh yes I did not burn you
completely yeah I just so like the
clicking the clicking is yeah it's a
really unpleasant really alarmingly
astonishingly unpleasant there we go it
just takes a little bit of okay
there they go okay goodbye goodbye
goodbye farewell no one will ever miss
you again okay was it down here I can't
remember where it was be - it was a here
yeah circuit breaker okay so I got to go
down I know probably was a way to go
around for this but I don't remember it
and I don't care because I needed to
burn these guys anyway so it's all for
the best
alright I mean not all for the best
probably for the worst but whatever
circuit no that wasn't it that's known
I'm looking for hello hello alright
probably turns on power in this area
actually hello more shotgun shells yes
please got so many of these okay this
one's Murph not muff Murph okay let's go
Murph examine let's tune it to Murph
okay MuRF oh we're almost there
easy peasy did done I know how that
works now oddly enough come on there we
go
easy got it nailed it I'm so good I
don't know why that's the system that
gets power on this place oh [ __ ]
cold drinks back up and ready all right
whatever let's go into the server room
which I imagine is where it wants me to
go next
hello anybody need to get burped very
good four servers I know earning it to a
crisp I am aware of this fact
hey fuel neato Hey all right okay how
you do this um maybe I should change out
for the shotgun yeah I don't need it
right away I think I'm good for now um
put this away I can make more shotgun
shells but I actually want to get two of
these because I want to get more mag
ammo because I love the bag I mean the
shotguns good but I love the Magno boom
and bang it is okay but for now let me
reload my dooble dagger
there we go I don't know how I'm
combining those but whatever okay store
that put that there put that there put
that there but that there put that there
this is not efficient in any way shape
or form put that there put that there
put that there put that there that there
and that there okay I'm good enough for
me save it up all right
server um good willow knife yes please
haven't had a knife in a bit okay I
think I'm good to go now there was
another door in here that probably got
opened up maybe a nursery that'd be nice
really dead space it up in here
oh you guys better be burdened dead
alright yes low temp testing lab oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no don't make me go in the cold
oh I don't want to go in the cold I
don't want to go in the cold no I don't
that's it's not where I want to go don't
even think about it
that's me dr. Lee all right can you
believe that bastard car right cool your
jets [ __ ] well I guess he is the boss
for now anyway have you seen my Hilux
anywhere I put the secret on the bottom
oh okay hang on wait I gotta go hang out
I gotta all right whatever I'll give you
something to do put together a budget
next year and get it done tonight
okay we're under attack people our daddy
Sarah cut off what is the bastard doing
plant 43 is going wild the greenhouse is
hell Suzie room you remember Suzie the
cheerleader what a great gal we were
both into her of course she wasn't into
nerds I still have to give you back
those comics that I borrowed but you
might have to wait a while yeah last one
a little little odd yeah okay so let's
examine this one secret at the bottom
you say I should have inspected this
before oh ah that's not exactly a secret
but that is helpful daddy's very helpful
so I know what that is about and I'll
get to that later
oh my god don't make me go in the cold I
don't want the cold it's cold Nicole
don't want to go in the cold I don't
wanna go in the cold so cold oh it's
cold in the cold that's what I like
about you Leon oh it's making light of
the situations okay put this in there I
guess I don't know I don't know air
solution is required to begin Oh
well I am just an idiot aren't I okay do
I need to come back I think I need to
come back okay I'm gonna come back real
cold real real cold hey the way that's
gunpowder in here what's real call real
cold guys got cold tit bit nipply in
here all right good man I wouldn't go in
there just because of - too big of a
risk they would actually freeze your
balls off and get locked in there get
locked in there and then freeze your
balls off that is the risk that I'm
actually worried about okay anyway
Lebowski I need to get to the lab that's
going to
I don't know this is the faster way but
I need to get back to the greenhouse cuz
I need to go around the greenhouse oh
[ __ ] Jesus Christ okay all right very
very scary very scary oh [ __ ]
you uh you're alright no that's not what
I want can I equip this please okay oh
[Applause]
wait whoops I still need it sure you can
have this excuse me you know what so
heartbreaking what I miss No god I feel
so bad
it's such a waste Oh Oh your big-ass
waste okay
whatever this was not the fastest way to
go but here I am a greenhouse here we go
this way oh I feel so bad okay I'll get
over it
uh-uh time to meet your maker what is
this again I'm looking and I'm seeing
with my eyes okay
Nia cute E that thing pac-man eating a
dot and then fat dick alright gotcha
you'd get E no not that one back e
pac-man and eating in a fat dick got it
nailed it okay good there we go now I
can fill this thing back in and get this
process started for some reason I think
I need to make it cold for some reason
I'm not 100% sure why but really I need
to make it cold so imma do that hello oh
here we go
alright can I get what I need
please please oh okay
uh and then I do this here and then I
switch these out and then I fill this
bad boy and boom I've got it easy peasy
lemon squeeze me I am such genius and my
brain is huge and big and girthy okay
so now what do I need to do cool it down
so what I need to do was that part of
the step procedure probably cool
immediately immediately okay I'm gonna
cool it I'm going I'm going to cool it
immediately I'm assuming I only got so
much time to be this song I'm gunning
for it I guess for some reason boo didi
this is not the quickest way to go but
anyway I always go this way I don't know
I here I go yeah how's it going
everybody hey how you doing it my name
is markiplier I'm here to cool something
you know how cool I am and all that jazz
and I'm not making a make it a lot of
sense all right here we go cool
immediately cool immediately and that is
the lulu lululu eel and three two one
cool immediately that in it tells me
okay how complex do you really how
complex doesn't need to be to cool it
I don't feel like you needed that much
robotics just to cool something down a
little bit well you know what what do I
know I'm not the scientist here I'm just
a police officer with an herbicide so
I'm gonna put this right here and then
I'm gonna go yeah all right I'm gonna
blast the ass out of whatever plant is
waiting to be blasted so that's all I
know and that's all I'm gonna do so
goodbye I guess
all right so boom if I go back out here
and up the stairs there gonna be one
more waiting for me but I'm hoping I can
just go right by him
hello how you doing would this guy go oh
oh there you are uh you're gonna be a
bit of a [ __ ] ain't ya
oh [ __ ] all right well perfect easy okay
let me say before I do this because who
knows what havoc I'm gonna wreak once
this goes under probably a lot store
that I've got a lot of shotgun shells
which is good I've also got I want to
make big boomer bangers I want to make
big boobies I really want to make big
boobies III know I've got shotgun shells
but I really like the lightning Hawk is
pretty cool so I'm gonna wait until I
get high-grade again all right
did I say if I probably did all right
let's do this we're going for it we're
going for a baby going for a baby
actually you know what I'm gonna get my
shotgun because I have a funkalicious
feeling that this is gonna somehow turn
into a boss fight I've just got this
weird funkalicious feeling I don't often
get funkalicious feelings but I've
really got a funkalicious feeling this
time around so I'm gonna take this out
put this right there put this there and
we're gonna see what happens because if
it goes down the way I think it's about
to go down then it is going to go down
in a blaze of glory
let's do this hey buddy I'm coming for
you don't you worry about a thing I am
coming to get you
it is going to be awesome and it is
going to be tight it is going to be
wicked it is going to be alright
alright let's pop this bad boy full of
poison whose goodness lose do this
Oh Judas there you go you got it there
we go that's better that's good that's
oh [ __ ]
chole [ __ ] alright that's sure dude I'm
gonna upgrade my wristband ain't names
gonna be nothing
okay all right I think I can handle that
I think I'm okay with that
I think honestly you know I've thought
about it considered it I'm okay with
that
I'm gonna take this and just gonna find
it with Mary Ann and there we go
you seem alive oh oh hey oh hi oh okay
um Wow hi oh hey how are you doing hey
buddy what the frickin Freaker prick
what the Frick
can you can you light on fire I don't
know oh [ __ ] oh boy oh [ __ ] I'm going
the wrong way
ah [ __ ] go ah [ __ ] okay ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he's very upset with
me I don't know where I need to go I've
got my upgraded ticket so I guess I just
need to go around yeah just gonna go
this way if nothing happened guts
frankly nothing did I am fine
everything's good and we're happy
everybody's happy see I'm happy
all's good in this neighborhood who
needs to worry about nothing not me not
me that's for sure not me no eh not me
no way let me just sneak a little loose
save real quick and bada-bing bada-boom
I don't need to worry about no tyrant
coming my way he is just a persistent
sack of [ __ ] but I am not worried about
that because he is not that big a deal
okay alright let's go let's do this he
ain't nobody anyway so it doesn't matter
I can just retract the bridge need be
we'd be nowhere he'd be nowhere right
you know where yeah probably probably
all right bingo bingo Bongo wasn't there
another computer in wait a minute wasn't
there another computer over oh [ __ ]
there was a computer over here that was
level 3 okay I need to go get that
because there was something I'm not
gonna forget about it because if I go if
I keep going for it I'm gonna forget
about it so I'm gonna go back he's not
gonna be in front of me he's not in
front of me oddly enough it was here
yeah right here so this thing yeah come
on
yeah we go okay when did nest become a
nest for spies three last month and
another for this month and those are
just ones we caught restricting access
to West nor request information on G
herbicide dispersal by unauthorized
employee okay alright well that was it
alright whatever
sure Cartwright is worried about spies
that's the only thing I learned about
that okay not necessarily the most
urgent of things to go back for but I'm
glad I gave them the less because it
could have been something amazing it
wasn't but it could have been so that's
the most important thing to remember all
right West area here we go
apparently we're gonna get the g-virus
which I highly doubt but you know one
can hope one can hope and if one keeps
hoping then nothing can stop me maybe
hello oh hey how you doing ooh very cool
very cool very cool and a grenade very
cool very cool very cool all right okay
so what is this boss you got it boss
done baby ah there we go
ah stun okay put that in there and boom
and we've got power which is again a
weird way to power a lab but I'm not
gonna complain about too much let's
watch this cassette let's watch a movie
everybody
dr. Bergin you'll come along with us
quietly I think I know you were coming
this is my life's work I'm not handing
over anything we have our orders
dr. Birkin I'll ask you one more time I
don't know man
just a rookie target resist it if we had
to take him on that's correct sir
Roger okay cut and dry easy sandals yep
but I remember from another cutscene
just barely that this same doctor that
was dead seemed to take a case full of
it and shove it in his gob and then it
mutated and then he was like oh my arm
I'm nightmare now and then that whole
thing happen so there's that the
Umbrella Corporation has decided to
cease all research on G which was
ongoing in the nests underground
laboratory all funding for this project
has been cut in the laboratory director
William Birkin has been removed from his
post lethally thank you for your email
dr. Burke and top brass is it compressed
and interested in involving bio app and
you have mentioned you're not worried
about costs our company is the most well
funded in the whole United States for
the good news Jesus almost ready strains
that you never thought to report to the
research lab here at umbrella it's cute
but I suppose I can let it slide anyway
send the data over and don't worry
you've done good work on G but you can
we can take care of the rest your honor
suspicion of breaching your contract
with the Umbrella Corporation is clear
that you claim to ownership the G
project and have been you're not the
authorized contact okay well that's not
good but it's not bad either so we'd say
it's it's like both right yeah
definitely I got a bad feeling about
this they don't have a save point but
they got a they got a case here and I'm
kind of confused as to why okay this
seems to be done so I'm a store that I'm
a store this so there's no save point
here so yeah it's just all right what
does that video player okay looky there
a blue herb that's good and we're good
here great oh hey this is fun Wow real
fancy here
oh is that high-grade oh yes please I'm
gonna go mix this up because I want it
I already said that I wanted it so I'm
gonna I'm gonna get it cuz I get I get
what I want daddy gets what he wants I
hate myself I get what I want
look god we should did anything but that
okay and okay we're gonna put this away
good to go let's do this whatever we're
going for which seems to be some kind of
a really intense whatever you have it
but it seems ominous so look I'm going
for it you oh no it's that scene from
the movie Resident Evil 1 they're gonna
cut me into pieces
oh no they're not oh this is so this is
such a confrontation oh this is so cool
oh but it's so confrontational but it's
so cool who's there Tyron is that you
huh you want some of this yeah anybody
want some of this oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh
research diary gee embryo implanted 50
centimeter incision in the chest kept
between 5015 lucid GCS 10 consciousness
level deteriorated subject disposed of
501 mutated in DG form was introduced 30
test subjects 2 hours 36 minutes was
observed in all the one playing with the
embryo disposed of one subject broke
down during experimentation took their
own life it's a little close
relationship 6 to 8 showed some signs of
resistance but had been implanted with
an embryo after 24 minutes T virus
resistance does nothing to stop the
mental deterioration caused by the
g-virus okay interesting the t-virus is
the thing that turns people into zombies
the g-virus is the thing that turns
people into monsters as far as I know
that's what I think anyway
maybe Oh easy enough alright well
with baby I might have done a goof
I may have goofed a little bit okay but
again this very much seems like some
kind of a very much seems like there's
some kind of a confrontation coming up
here soon so kind of worried about it
but you know it is what it is I guess um
let's make some shoddy ammo I guess okay
we got lots of shotgun ammo that's all
we need
i'ma take out another one of these and
bada-bing bada-boom
okay we're as good as we're gonna be it
seems like it seems like a lot to blow
up the whole facility just because some
virus got out
any minute now called a oh hey hey
friend how you doing
you are looking so fine
what's going on
I call this thing William why Briella
hold this hold this
your umbrella too you tell me you
weren't involved in this yes but we
never meant for this to happen tell me
everything right from the start
[Music]
you don't get away that easily
[Music]
good god William what have you done so
you made this monster we made the
g-virus but we never intended this
minute anyway you want
oh that's our way
oh ok easy enough thanks
makes sense I get it you get it we get
it
they don't you get it I get it alright
let's run away as fast as I can
can I run oh [ __ ] this is not runnable
hi oh god please stop hurting me you
heard so much there's a flashbang over
here I wish I done that sooner
alright whatever I'm just gonna oh okay
that's convenient
I guess alright I'll take some of this
I'll take some of that and that's a lot
of bullets and oh that's that's uh
excuse me muah ha ha
excuse my I'm just gonna collect
everything Rudy
hey grenade yes bullet don't mind if I
do
let's see uh Oh what is this here I
don't mind me just gonna okay alright
well this is going great I'm just gonna
take this flashbang and right yep was
for me and oh don't mind if I do
this stock up time apparently alright
little little itty Latta lately - okay
that's sad
wow that's popped your eye huh oh [ __ ]
is that important that seems like it
might be important
shoot that a bit okay I don't know what
that data and I don't know why that was
that but I'm assuming that oh [ __ ] he's
he's kind of just kind of pissed maybe I
should do one of these maybe
oh boy now it's pretty impressive okay I
heard okay it's starting to hurt now
starting to hurt real bad
there we go uh-huh
okay on to the big boomers
are you thinking [ __ ] um okay
see you
Oh
okay
Oh
good got it yeah well okay good great
does that mean we're gonna blow up or
whines are we gonna blow up are we gonna
blow am i gonna blow up do I blow up is
this where I blow up you know honestly I
mean I made out of this like a bandit
I've got so many bullets
oh so many bullets I've never had more
bullets than I have right now I've got
I've got so many bullets I mean I'm out
of shotgun and and boom banger ammo but
I got so many bullets hey you're still
here I didn't expect that actually I did
not expect that into at all a little bit
stick my fingers in there yeah it's bad
I got some spray it's going the FBI
you trust that [ __ ] what's that
supposed to mean
she's not FBI
she's a mercenary what are you talking
about no way jeepers
go to my love
[Music]
that's what you get for bad-mouthing my
girlfriend that's what you get
how could you betray me my love is
eternal but I can't believe you would oh
not my girlfriend who you you okay
whatever you know it's fine it's fine
you know it's fine it's fine
I bought the unbelievably livid that you
would do something like that to my
girlfriend okay
it's fine that's not good I don't have I
don't have a level 4 clearance did you
have a level 4 clearance I cuz I don't
have a level 4 clearance can I get your
wristband do you have a wristband that I
can get can I steal no okay all right
well all right well you know is it five
is definitely 100% fine totally fine
yeah okay you got it I'm in it to win it
hello hi hey hey babe oh honey
pumpkin is thinking about you sugar
lumps makes two of us
I was getting worried no we make a good
team I'm gonna ask you something waste
clear
tell me you got it I got it let me
verify did you sample we get the hell
out of here before we do that I ran into
a net
she claims you're not FBI
why couldn't you just hammer this
as I realized as much as I want to trust
you I didn't
I really hope to know
so that's all this was I was just some
pawn to you look I'm just doing my job
and I'm doing mine so drop that damn gun
I'm taking you in
hand over the sample Leon I don't want
to hurt you
and you shoot me but I don't think you
can I wouldn't play that game no wait I
don't I'm not gonna play that game no I
know I'm not playing that game
Oh
that's not good that's that's not good
man people don't stay dead in this game
whoo cuz it's a zombie game I get it
forget it I've got you honey I love
girlfriend sweetums Snickers
No buh-buh-bear take care of yourself a
newer for a day or not oh well live and
learn then get loves let's move on time
to get out of here
escape the lab wait sir anything else in
this lab that I need um not that I know
of
I think I saw everything right didn't I
didn't I see everything I guess I I just
go
Hey yes I go shouldn't I just go some
ten minutes seems like a long time to
get gone oh I'm going down oh ah okay
all right then
right
right oh yeah
yowza that doesn't look good I I think
it's got a fever all right cool
I mean I am I don't know what else I can
do
maybe a little faster ah
Oh first spray what are they given or
spray okay that's a lot of times that
player oh yeah but the whole place is
coming down
listen to me you need to get out fast
yes there's a way out we can make it
where are you now Claire you still there
take me on you're breaking up forget
about me just get out of here dammit
alright good great
that helped I think well another knife
we'll take it sure why not
I don't know why I have so much stuff
but I've got a lot of bullets and I
don't know what to do with them
oh that looks important alright umm so
that's all the time I got for this
episode which is great because we've got
a ticking clock and I don't know what's
coming next but if the game finishes at
the very beginning of the next episode
that's great because then we get to
start clear story but I have a funny
feeling that this ending where it says
ten minutes is gonna be another thirty
minutes anyway so I'm not gonna finish
it in this one so it's gonna be a
cliffhanger the whole place is going up
my love that I've loved for all of the
one one thousandth of my life probably
less than that he's gone
ada is gone with the virus no no who do
she had a parachute in that song of hers
but she's gone Oh boohoo I'm so sad but
Claire's there maybe I could fall in
love with her in two seconds it
shouldn't take that long but we'll see
what happens in the next episode thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]